Росія видобуває стільки ж нафти, скільки до війни в Україні.
І продає в ЄС більше зрідженого газу, ніж будь-коли раніше.
Як таке може бути? Адже Євросоюз і країни Великої сімки
домовилися про санкції проти російського експорту нафти й газу ще влітку 2022 року.
Санкції стали реакцією на повномасштабне вторгнення Росії в Україну.
Але поки що вони майже не дали ефекту, навіть навпаки.
У 2018 році Росія експортувала близько 8 мільйонів барелів нафти на день.
Протягом останніх п'яти років цей обсяг залишався практично незмінним.
Один із санкційних заходів - танкерам, які перевозять російську нафту,
заборонили заходити в порти ЄС і країн Великої сімки.
Крім того, суттєво обмежується постачання нафти до Європи наземними трубопроводами.
Але реальність інша.
Десятки нафтових танкерів, у тому числі з країн Великої сімки,
чекають на заповнення нафтою біля російських портів, таких як Новоросійськ і Мурманськ.
Вони доставляють нафту через Середземне море.
Або, як цей російський танкер, через Берингове море. Переважно в Азію.
Санкції спочатку призвели до здешевлення російської нафти.
Тож нафтопереробні заводи в Азії скористалися можливістю
і розширили своє виробництво, наприклад, таких видів палива, як бензин і дизель,
Саме тому Індія та Китай купують більше російської сирої нафти через низькі ціни.
Вони можуть перепродавати нафтопродукти на світовому ринку за вищими цінами.
Однією з причин, чому Індія та Китай збільшили споживання російської сирої нафти, є знижені ціни.
У багатьох випадках ці країни купують дешевшу сиру нафту
та продають нафтопродукти на світовому ринку з надбавкою.
Ще один санкційний захід - обмеження ціни на російську нафту на рівні 60 доларів за барель,
що приблизно на 20 доларів нижче за ринкову ціну.
Країни Великої сімки та ЄС ухвалили таке рішення наприкінці 2022 року.
Але і це не працює. Як таке можливо?
Це пов’язано з механізмом обмеженням ціни, який дозволяє західним компаніям,
таким як судноплавні компанії, трейдери та страхові компанії,
продовжувати сприяти торгівлі російською нафтою у світі.
Одна з причин - у торгівлі нафтою є лазівки, а західні компанії недостатньо контролюються.
Чи можна цьому якось протидіяти?
"А" - переконатися, що обмеження ціни працює.
Торгівля повинна контролюватися, і всі компанії повинні дотримуватися правил.
І "Б" - як тільки це спрацює, наступним кроком буде ще більше знизити максимальну ціну.
Наступна проблема - процвітаюча торгівля зрідженим газом у Росії.
Санкції проти російського газу, який надходить до Європи по трубопроводах, працюють.
Але до європейських портів потрапляють дедалі більші обсяги російського зрідженого газу.
У 2021 році було поставлено 16 мільярдів кубометрів ЗПГ.
У перший рік війни у 2022 році - 22, а в 2023 році вже було поставлено 13 мільярдів кубометрів,
і до кінця року, за оцінками, буде понад 22 мільярди кубометрів.
Цього року ЄС закупив у Кремля зрідженого газу на 5,3 млрд євро.
Слід знати, що торгівля російським ЗПГ в Європі не обмежується.
ЄС не хоче вводити санкції щодо російського зрідженого газу до 2027 року.
А тим часом санкції було запроваджено не лише проти російських нафти і газу,
але й проти цілих російських галузей, зокрема авіації.
Під забороною опинилися як купівля нових літаків, так і запчастин до них.
Але й тут виявилося чимало лазівок.
Без нових запчастин, без сертифікованого технічного обслуговування
та без міжнародних перевезень авіалайнери у Росії продовжують літати.
Трохи менше половини з них були у лізингу і належать іноземним компаніям.
Але ці літаки Росія присвоїла.
Російській авіагалузі пророкували серйозну кризу.
Але цього так і не сталося.
Авіакомпанія "Побєда" експлуатує, здається, 41 літак Boeing 737/800.
Зрозуміло, що їм уже потрібно було би щось розібрати, замінити запчастини,
але якщо ми подивимося за реєстрами, то всі літаки "Побєди" успішно літають,
причому літають майже щодня.
Журналісти-розслідувачі видання "Важливі історії" з'ясували:
російські компанії продовжують закуповувати запчастини та агрегати для літаків.
Тільки роблять це тепер не через офіційних постачальників,
а через посередників, які не розповідають, куди в підсумку підуть ці запчастини.
Вони купують ці запчастини буцімто для себе.
В основному це так звані "дружні" країни - Арабські Емірати, Туреччина, Китай, країни СНД.
І вони вводять в оману західні компанії, кажуть, що ці деталі призначаються не для Росії.
Швидше за все підробляють документи, адже постачальники зазвичай намагаються перевірити, куди йдуть їхні запчастини.
Постачальники думають, що вони йдуть куди завгодно, але не в Росію.
А вони зрештою опиняються в Росії.
У таких сірих схемах часто беруть участь одразу кілька компаній-посередників.
З'ясувати, хто кінцевий покупець, почасти неможливо, оскільки далеко не всі країни діляться митними даними.
До таких країн, наприклад, належать Об'єднані Арабські Емірати.
Не завжди компанії-виробники в змозі відстежити ланцюги поставок.
І це досить нова і складна конструкція з точки зору контролю з боку регуляторів.
І тому ми бачимо, що через це діряве сито через різні канали та різні країни
до Росії надходять товари подвійного призначення, включаючи агрегати для авіаційної галузі,
аеронавігаційне обладнання та якісь інші елементи, електроніка, наприклад.
Найбільший покупець авіазапчастин - російська компанія "Аерофлот".
Загалом за такими схемами журналісти нарахували закупівель на 18 мільярдів рублів.
Тут зазначу, йдеться лише про запчастини саме до "Боїнгів" та "Ейрбасів",
бо ці компанії одразу після початку війни оголосили свою позицію.
Є ще велика кількість літаків і запчастин від різних інших постачальників, і вони в цю суму не входять.
Тобто насправді ми говоримо про ще більшу суму.
Деякими компаніями-посередниками володіють російські громадяни, іншими - іноземці.
Причому частина з них на ринку нещодавно.
Зараз час, можна сказати, "ельдорадо" для таких тіньових торговців, посередників, тіньових брокерів,
які заробляють якщо не десятки мільйонів, то точно мільйони доларів на посередницьких схемах.
Ми бачимо, наскільки вільно почуваються такі посередники в цих різних юрисдикціях,
і з тими обсягами коштів, якими вони оперують.
Припускаю, що значну частину цих коштів російська держава просто готова переплачувати вдвічі, втричі, вдесятеро просто тому,
що немає жодної альтернативи для російського військово-промислового комплексу.
Найбільші корпорації - "Боїнг" та "Ейрбас" - намагаються контролювати продаж.
Але відстежити всі ланцюги поставок, як показує практика, не в змозі.
Не вдається це поки що й контролюючим органам.
За порушення санкцій зазвичай загрожує кримінальна відповідальність.
Але вона діє тільки на території Європи та США, чим користуються "сірі" бізнесмени з інших країн.